welcome to a fresh take on the issues
that matter to you
asking the hard questions and putting
the public at the center of the national
conversation
this is the great debate
[Applause]
each week we'll be taking a deeper look
at the issue dominating the headlines
this week
after the murder of sarah everard and
the more than 80 women who have been
killed by men since then
what needs to change
our viewers panel drawn from around the
country will share their stories they'll
have their say
and they'll put their questions to our
studio guests
and in the studio this week we're joined
by former home secretary amber rudd
ex-metropolitan police detective colin
sutton
women's rights and diversity campaigner
femi otitoju
and the daily mail columnist sarah vine
the big question facing them all tonight
are women safe on our streets
do i walk quicker do i have my keys
ready in my pocket it's getting darker
earlier we need to change what we're
doing now my friends bought us all rape
alarms we're just being extra vigilant
it's opened a lot of people's eyes that
you're not safe wherever you go are
there things we need to do yes there are
all of us want to feel safe and be safe
we now have a voice and we need to make
sure that women are heard if anybody has
any doubts about police officers call
999 what point does the perseverance of
fear make me not live my life
and as always let's go straight to our
viewers panel this week we've had an
extraordinary response from many of you
incredible but your own experiences of
harassment of abuse of assault
i want to start with helen femi williams
in london helen hi um thanks for having
me um
i guess first i would say and if i was
to share my experience i feel like you
know for a long time um black people and
brown people across um the uk have
always had this kind of distrust towards
the police for years but potentially
maybe because um the narrative has kind
of seeped into kind of mainstream
society now that's something that people
are actually talking about and thinking
about because like i remember as early
as when i was in school for instance
um i was like when i was in school and
in my uniform i would have um there was
a particular man who used to kind of ask
me to come home with him and he would
pay me and things of that nature
and i remember reporting it to school i
remember my parents going to to um the
police about it and it was kind of taken
in rather than it being taken very
seriously like wow like so like this
person's still in school and someone's
approaching her it was more sort of like
well you know
um don't really have much evidence and
it was kind of dropped and to be honest
i still see that person to this day i
still see him and i sort of think if i
was in a more vulnerable vulnerable
position would it be or like if i was
someone who came from um who needed the
money would you would if he's just if
he's approaching me he could be
approaching other kids to this day
asking you know for them to come home
and things of that nature thank you
helen i want to go
now to a viewer
who told us that she does want to share
her story
but um i think viewers will understand
uh why she does not want uh her face uh
or her name to be known can you tell us
what happened to you
i have been um attacked twice um at the
age of 31 i was out on an evening with
some friends
and um i believe i was drugged and got
into what i thought was a taxi
and somebody else got into the taxi i
remember fighting with them in the back
and then my body was dumped on waste
ground
and
some people found me they sent me home
and i did report to the police i went
for all forensic testing
and they
nothing came of that and
i chased it
and still nothing really came of it
and then three years ago and a
younger gentleman pushed saying
gentlemen not a gentleman a younger man
pushed his way into my home
um i woke up in the middle of the night
after passing out and this this man was
in my bed
and he
he shushed me back to sleep i passed out
again
i believe i was drugged again and i had
my underwear ripped off me
i had um
i woke up again and he was sexually
assaulting me and i fought him off and
got him out of my house
and i went to the police felt i was
my character was being judged and
again i had to chase it i found out
further information about this this man
that he um did these sort of things on a
regular basis i told the police and they
said
and i wasn't telling them anything that
they didn't already know but there was
no evidence
and as far as i'm aware this man still
lives local i live in fear i live in
fear all the time and it's affected me
as a mother it's affected me with my job
and what i wear i'm not safe at home i'm
not safe out of the home and
where is my safe place who's going to
protect me
and boris johnson talks about you know
the one and a half percent that go to
court and and we've got to make this
make this um quicker this process
quicker but what about the 98.5
that don't go to court and the people
that are suffering
you know this just doesn't go away
because you don't go to court this is
this is something you have to live with
you're suffering constantly
every man unless you've actually been a
victim of this kind of crime you will
not understand how you fear every man
and
and you don't want to fear every man you
don't want to be
um
you know
looking over your shoulder every time a
man walks past you you don't want to be
changing your clothes because you might
be thinking you know is he looking at me
in a certain way
it totally totally changes the way that
you live your life my whole perspective
i don't let my my girls go out um
anywhere where i don't know where
they're going
it is a life of health for the victim
and and even just because it doesn't go
to court doesn't mean that that
we are not suffering and and it's so
it's not just about speeding up the
process for getting it to court it's
about picking up the pieces and
rebuilding your life and where is my
support because my doctor tells me it's
two years before i get to see a
psychiatrist together
normal a formal uh diagnosis of ptsd so
with some proper
medication to help me
and in the meantime i'm waiting
every
one of us here in the studio and i think
on the wall
is holding our breath as you speak to us
uh
it's impossible
certainly for me to imagine
what you've been through and
first of all
i just want to say thank you
for having the courage to come and speak
to us but i hope if you stay watching
you may get at least beginnings of an
answer thank you
i want to come next to
liz lowry in abernathy
liz we could see that you were
signaling and i think you have a
question which to some extent comes
out of what we've just heard
yes trevor my question is why can't
women go out at night or indeed at any
time and feel safe
thank you liz
we're now
getting down to a rather specific
aspect
of what we heard from
the lady we can't name
why
um why can't we go out at night before i
come to our panel liz why do you think
the that women can't go tonight what is
the answer to that question from your
point of view
unfortunately trevor from my point of
view it's the behavior of a minority of
men
and just the general culture
all right we will come to those wider
questions let's turn to the panel in the
studio here with liz's question
why can't women go out at night and feel
safe amber rudd
well let's put her finger in the last
point which is an issue of culture
what we're talking about here is male
violence
and in the last
two incidents we heard about
there was unsatisfactory response from
the police and of course the police are
at the core
of this terrible murder of sarah everard
and
quite rightly people are asking why
can't we rely on the police and i was
very struck too by the second woman's
point that she would no longer trust the
police even though her experience had
been pretty bad she would trust them
even less now and we have to do
something about that and to me
what i see is that the culture of the
police not of all of them but of some of
them does not take the sort of violence
against women that we've been seeing
seriously enough and that needs to
change femi autotroju do you
agree with what amber rudd just said i
completely agree that it's culture that
needs to be tackled
and it's a wider thing as well it's not
just
male violence against women it's also
all the other little things in culture
that contribute to and shore up that
male violence so we're talking about
pornography we're talking about the
sexualization of women and girls
in everything from advertising to
clothing and it all contributes to this
idea of women being
available that's what we need to tackle
we're here at seeing a lot of agreement
from our audience colin sutton um
you were a cop um this is wider than the
police
oh for sure it's wider than the police
in the sense that that prosecutions take
place within the criminal justice system
and where prosecution can't take place
and and let's let's you know remember
that even
people accused of violence against women
or rape
have the right to work within the
criminal justice system and and to be
defended and to have the evidence
support against them so where that can't
be brought as we heard there it seems
that
there are inadequate support mechanisms
for those
unsatisfied victims if you like but i
agree with with amber and with femi it's
a cultural thing now in terms of culture
within the police service of course the
commissioner has announced today that
she's going to have an independent
review done of the culture within the
police and
as am said absolutely right it's a very
small minority but a two larger minority
in the police who have this this idea um
that that that crimes against women
aren't a priority
wider culture wider culture is
how do we how do we bring our boys up
how do we bring men up
sarah vine we'll come to the issue
specifically of the police in a moment
but are you in agreement with our
panelists that there is a much larger
cultural question that we need to tackle
i think attitude towards women have
actually been going backwards in the
last two or three decades and i think a
lot of that is to do with the
availability of hardcore online porn
and um
you know what people
it's it is about
a sort of ingrained culture in which
women are abused uh raped mistreated
categorized as you know
uh
loose moral whatever if if you've ever
seen any of this stuff which i've had to
do for various work you know i've had to
watch this stuff for various reports
that i've done on it it is inherently
misogynistic and the the narrative is
that all women are available all women
are desperate to have sex with men all
of the time
that it's okay for 10 or 12 men to have
sex with one woman for a prolonged
period of time and to you know all of
this kind of stuff and if you've got
that if that's coming into people's
minds at quite a young age it permeates
through and it percolates i want to come
back to that
broad question of the environment and
you know pornography and so forth
but
let's just see whether
on the issue of culture that you've all
been discussing what the mood in the
country is
we commission an opinion poll for this
program
and one of the questions we asked was
are sexist views common among men in
britain
74 of women said yes
and 59 percent of men agreed femi does
that surprise you this is why we don't
feel safe on the streets at night
because we have been taught our mothers
teachers our friends teach us that we
have to take care and that we are the
ones responsible and that's actually the
point
amber rad it's it's an extraordinary
situation that we live in a country
where half the population
feel they need to take
what are essentially extreme measures
for fear
and we're reflecting on that now in the
wake of this terrible murder but most of
us particularly of my age and with my
daughter we grow up expecting that
but hopefully this is a moment when we
look at the culture and try to change
that
because it's completely wrong and i it
feels to me like people are going to
push for cultural change and that could
happen if the men as well
reject the situation that we're in now
it mustn't just be the women saying so
well i was rather surprised it didn't
entirely surprise me that 74 percent of
women
think that
men being sexist is common but i was
quite surprised that 59 of men agreed
yes of course that's being sexist which
can be lighter than let's face it
misogyny which is what we're talking
about which is much more likely to lead
to aggression of some sort
sarah vine
what did you think about the those poll
results the 74 59 percent i think it's
encouraging that that many men
recognize that there's a problem i mean
you know i'm not i'm not one of those
people who thinks that all men are
rapists i'm really not and i think there
are majority of men are actually
horrified by this sort of thing so you
know
in a moment we'll be asking
uh where the sense of male entitlement
that creates this culture comes from and
what to do about it
it's not just boys being boys what we're
doing is actually disrespectful
education we need to educate everyone
but it probably starts with everyone and
especially men acknowledging what a
problem this is a lot of boys will sit
there thinking i'm not part of that i
don't do that the problem with violence
against women are the people who
perpetrate that violence and make women
feel threatened are you teaching the men
around you your friends your sons your
parents what are you doing to help the
problem
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they've pushed the protesters further
back here as around two or three hundred
[Music]
west of england correspondent
[Music]
this van goes onto the streets of
plymouth seven days a week 365 days a
year
[Music]
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region hearing from people
who have real stories
i have nowhere to live for
about three or four months
there are still people inside the
properties here
they are coming from the epicentre of
what is now a global health pandemic
we were seeing and speaking to young
women who were selling themselves right
on the high street it was desperately
sad what we need is to get obviously
softballer girls from work if we need
more help
[Music]
before brexit these oysters were being
exported to the eu but the trade stopped
what's your overnight about the future
though blake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
welcome back to the great debate are
women safe on our streets before the
break we heard a lot about women's
experiences
but we started to talk a bit about men's
behavior
so i want to come back to
the wall
and talk to
our viewer josh morrison
josh what do you think
hey trevor uh so yeah i'm 26 years old
uh i've been living pretty much in a
modern society for quite some time i've
worked at bars i've worked at clubs some
being quite big clubs where footballers
are in
i've worked at festivals and i've always
been
sober which means i'm able to see what
you guys are all talking about actually
on the streets
and yeah i think my question is as
follow uh the uk both in history and in
today's society has quite a lot of toxic
male culture
uh where does the panel think this stems
from so i kind of want to get to the
root of this
josh thank you so much well look uh come
back into coming back into the studio
josh asked the question
the uk is full of toxic
male culture where does this stem from
femi
well it starts early because in some
schools i've been working with children
as young as 12 and 13 and the girls have
been saying we are being sexually
assaulted in schools so
where does it come from these children
are learning it from
potentially their parents
the people that raise them and educate
them and they're certainly learning it
from the media that they consume
when you say they're learning from a
media what sort of thing are you talking
about
i'm talking about television programs
and films that show women being abused
as a matter of course that show
young men that they're entitled to
access to women's bodies and everything
from tick-tock to
magazines all perpetuate that idea colin
um
a lot of this is about young men
and uh you
in your career must have dealt with
friday and saturday nights tumbling out
where do you think it's coming from
is it new i don't think it's new at all
no i mean it was 40 years ago now that i
first had the rough and tumble friday
and saturday night at nightclubs
alcohol plays a big part drugs plays a
big part um i don't think it's a
necessarily uk
problem as the question suggested it's
it's you know going back in history
there has always been this sort of
patriarchy
there's always been this sort of male
dominance and and
we're probably at a point in history
where we're getting closest to breaking
that down but there's still a long way
to go
okay josh um
you've heard from femi and colin and
both of them are saying it starts young
in fact colin says it's always been
there do you agree
yeah i can see where they're coming from
i want to also bring up another point
in something that's really big in
today's life is role models you know
we've seen also in the last couple of
months a lot of media coming out about
football players you know this country
is one of the largest football driven
countries in the world but what we're
also seeing is those role models are not
being able to play the the role that
they they're meant to play
um yes some of them are doing incredible
things and doing incredible charity but
let's really not be around the bush here
there's also a lot of
male influence here that is really
really strong
sarah you write for um one of the
biggest selling newspapers covers a lot
of celebrities and stars do you
identify with what josh says
i i agree with them but i mean people
like marcus rashford have completely
changed the landscape for footballers i
think and even someone like you know
lewis hamilton you know even if you you
know just male sports stars in general
are
the younger generation seem to be much
less toxic in that respect i think music
has a big part to play i have to be
honest i think a lot of the music that
young men listen to today is very um
is very misogynistic it really is i mean
if you if you ever sat down and listened
to some of the lyrics they really are
quite shocking and and again it's it's
this whole thing of legitimizing and
normalizing these very unpleasant
attitudes towards women you know it's
okay
you know if it's just you doing it you
might think it's a bit wrong but if
there's 20 of you or if there's 100 of
you and suddenly you know the person is
selling millions of albums well then
it's fine it's got to be fine because
otherwise someone would stop it wouldn't
they okay with the greatest of respect i
don't think anybody in the studio is
exactly in a position to get the tenor
of the mood of the young of young
britain so let's go back to our wall
where we do have some people who might
be able to help us with that let me
start with uh jamie beaston jamie urine
beast
beeston in nottinghamshire i beg your
pardon jamie
so i i think that
i think the sexualization of women um in
music um
is awful um and it's overlooked because
you know people are listening to the
music
and they're not actually noticing what
people are saying about women is
completely wrong when is somebody going
to stop what they are saying and make
people realize what they're saying is
completely wrong
we are talking about the kind of music
that describes women
uh i think i'm safe to say this even on
this program uh as [ __ ] maybe that
sort of thing
absolutely yeah but and that's not just
a new thing we've been seeing that since
well we've seen that in the last what 20
you know 30 years um the emergence of
pop and rap it's been it's been going on
for a long time okay
let me let's come to a young woman aisha
gill is also 16 and esha i think you're
in bexley heath in southeast london
yes
what do you make of this do you agree
with what
jamie's just said in response to josh's
question
yeah i do agree i think that there is a
certain culture with young people and
especially sort of in secondary schools
um that culture is within young boys and
i think
you know there isn't any
quick fix for this problem um but there
are things that can be implemented in
schools uh in terms of the education
system
and things like
pshe and social education lessons where
you know young boys can be taught about
sexual assault harassment and consent
things that you know are really
important and you know maybe older
generations haven't been taught about it
but i think it is important to now as we
modernize to teach young boys about it
we should be educating our sons instead
of telling our daughters how to dress
you know it's is it that people believe
that it's sort of all on young women
okay there's there's a lot of support
and i can see people clapping in the
audience let me to ask you both esha and
jamie
echa just talked about behavior in
schools harassment and so on
talk to me about how that actually
expresses itself give me an example let
me start with you asia
um so
you know we've had not personally me but
i've
just in general that
sort of young boys will make comments
about girls to their friends and sort of
you know boys will be boys kind of thing
like it's not boys will be boys that's
sexualizing a young girl somebody who
you know i'm 15 16 but you know somebody
who may be
15 or 14 and that that's just wrong
jamie um
when you talk to your friends or when
you listen to other boys at school
what sort of thing is what kind of
conduct
do you
feel
is leading to this kind of problem
well i think it's the the normalization
of of talking about younger women and
women in general
um in in a manner like that and and
allowing it to happen within your group
of friends i think
if if people are talking about women in
in that way in your group of friends you
should absolutely pull them to aside and
tell them that is wrong
do you think most young people have the
courage to call it out i mean it it's
quite tough isn't it with your mates
yeah i think i think a lot of people
tend to just you know just go along with
it they don't want to cause them you
know maybe an issue um in in their group
when they should absolutely call out
what is wrong
okay let's come back in the studio femi
in your professional life i guess you
might get called in to
help address this kind of thing in a
workplace maybe even in school what
would you do well the first thing i'd
say is we need to have some mechanisms
that uh make it easy for people to tell
when they've been on the receiving end
of those kinds of behaviors then we need
to have people trained enough to be able
to intervene effectively and there needs
to be support mechanisms for them but
most of all there needs to be really
strong messaging from the leadership
that this behavior will not be tolerated
and swift action decisive action will be
taken because people do it men do it
boys do it because they believe they can
get away with it and they do
amber what would you advise if you were
asked to call in femi to get her to come
in and give us some advice i was very
struck by jamie's point about
normalization thing and if it's not
called out then it just people think
they've got away with it and they carry
on and then it'll get it'll get worse
and worse and more sort of
more aggressive and i think that's one
of the problems we have
okay
a little earlier we were talking about
the loss of confidence and trust in the
police
so coming up we're going to get your
views
i think what's going to really scare
people is being stopped by the police
now questions that will need to be
answered by the metropolitan police i
don't think women feel safe around
police officers
should we have confidence in the vision
we believe in policing absolutely no
police force in the country have
properly prioritized violence against
women and girls there are those who feel
their trust in us is shaken if you can't
trust the people you know you are
supposed to trump who can you trust
[Applause]
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
[Applause]
this is the great debate where this week
we're asking are women safe on our
streets
jen lamedy you're in macclesfield
you've got a question for our panel on
this
yeah as somebody's always um trusted the
police i want to know can we trust the
police in like light of the um the
information we've all received in the
last couple of weeks
that's a very straightforward question
from jen lamidy
can we trust the police
amber rudd
the police have acknowledged and crested
dick the head of the met has
acknowledged that trust has been broken
and i think that we all know why and
they need to rebuild it i think the
thing that i found following the
devastating murder almost as shocking
was the catalogue of errors that have
been made
and the incidents that have been taken
lightly
like the indecent exposure and the
description of a whatsapp exchange where
police officers were exchanging
misogynistic
messages and what i felt we got a
picture of
was a group of misogynistic police
officers
which is where you start
leading up to some sort of violence male
violence doesn't happen in a vacuum it's
on the bed of that sort of misogyny and
i ultimately i'm not saying that's
anywhere near all of police officers but
what has been revealed is this
misogynistic exchange between police
officers that worries me did you have
any sense that this was what it was like
when you were home secretary i have to
say i didn't and i think a lot of people
who know the met well and know other
police forces well have been surprised
at the level i took the chart over the
weekend i spoke to a friend of mine
who's a probationer
and she's in her second year and she has
been
shocked by some of the that phrase again
the normalizing of misogynistic
exchanges of women being treated in a
certain way of going to attend domestic
abuse victims and going through the
motions but then afterwards there is a
real problem and it feels even worse
that it's in the police and not just you
know on the sports field or something
which would be pretty unpleasant and i
think there was a real job a vital job
in cleaning up the culture of the police
colin um
this may be an awkward way to put this
to you but
you're not going to tell me nobody knew
this
it would be interesting in the wake of
what's happened in the last week if
the polling is repeated which has been
done over many years
to see how trust in the police has been
dented because traditionally
they've always come up quite high in
trustworthiness certainly above
politicians and journalists
this will have dented it there's no
doubt about that
i don't think the leadership in the
police were aware and indeed amber when
you were home secretary you were
arguably at the pinnacle of that
leadership and you said you weren't
aware of it
it's something i wasn't aware of when i
was a reasonably middle-ranking position
in the police
uh but whatsapp groups want a thing then
um
it needs reviewing well this came up in
an exclusive poll that we commissioned
for the great debate we asked to what
extent if at all do you trust the
metropolitan police in london
overall 42 percent of people said they
do not trust them
just 33 percent said they do trust them
sarah vine
we could have known this couldn't we
well i think the thing is that i mean my
daughter's 18 and she has lots of young
friends and they would the last thing
they would do is call the police if they
were in trouble i mean almost the last
thing that there is no sense that the
police will listen to you take you
seriously there's a real sort of
hostility i think
um
and there's a disconnect and i think
it's to do with you know you said
earlier there were no whatsapp groups
there the all the the barriers
to behavior have come have all come down
and it's like
the things that perhaps were festering
underneath have now sort of bubbled up
and that's what we're seeing with these
police officers saying things that
perhaps you know previously they would
never have done because they'd never
have had the
the sort of environment in which to be
able to do it and to think that they
could get away with it and i think that
you know i hear all the time tales of
sexual assault amongst my daughter's
friends
and they are really frightening and
really horrible and none of them as far
as i know would ever go to police i feel
like there's a huge gap developing here
when sarah speaking before about
the feeling of lack of trust there was
applause from within the wall here and
it feels like there's a huge gap between
what
the police think about themselves and
what everybody else thinks about
themselves about them femi well i think
i would be
negligent as a parent i'm not a parent
but i've got nieces and nephews if i
were to go to my young black nieces and
nephews and say to them today you should
trust the police that would be stupid i
have to say to them today
you need to be careful with your
interactions with the police and it's
not because i believe every single
police officer is bad and will sexually
assault or you know young black men have
their own you know concerns it's because
we don't know which ones
are going to behave in that way and we
don't know when they're going to
encounter them and i also need to say
that it is practically criminal that
these people can sit here and say i had
no idea that it was like that because it
speaks today right now to say we need to
connect with the community we need to do
it fast and we need to make sure that
those connections are absolutely
watertight they have to stay there all
right let me come back to the wall
you've been hearing
views both on our poll and from in the
studio about
the
issue of trust in the police now i want
to come and ask you
has your
trust and confidence in the police been
lessened by what you've learned in the
last week can i see those who feel that
their
trust and confidence in police has been
lessened in the last week
actually in fact i was about to say it
was just about a third but
in fact pretty much everybody has lost
confidence by what they've learned in
the last week
amber
that's
pretty catastrophic if you are a police
leader isn't it it is
it is and that's why they need to have
an independent investigation which i
know that
crested dick has announced today
in the met to try to get to the bottom
of how that culture can be changed which
i think is the most important element of
what we're trying to address here
given what we've just seen
is cressida dick really the person to
lead that whatever her virtues and her
past
has she now gone beyond
a place where anything she touches
can be trusted by
these viewers people out there travis
she's got the support of the prime
minister and the home secretary so
that's two there's another 64 5 million
yeah but we know how these things work
she's i she said she's staying she's
going to try and find the answers and
she set out the program for doing so i i
personally i think that if you get a new
leader in there you just give a pause to
what needs to happen while new leader
beds in and then tries to find a new way
of doing it i'd much rather that she got
on and made those changes and
felt the responsibility which she
clearly does to be the person having
overseen over the past few years those
changes through all right i know that
the conversation about the police is
going to carry on but let's pause there
for a moment because
when you come back is porn part of the
problem
[Music]
[Music]
what we found in 2020 was that many
people were drinking more than they
usually would about the height of the
pandemic
this research that we're publishing
today
shows that most people have returned to
their pre-pandemic levels of drinking
however for some people for people who
are already drinking at levels are
putting their mental or physical health
at risk which we refer to as high-risk
drinkers a third of those drinkers are
still drinking more than they usually
would
which implies this data implies that
these habits are now becoming ingrained
anyone can be a high-risk drinker and
many people who drink at risky levels
might not be aware of it for this
research we used a world health
organization validated tool which
involves three questions and
looks at how frequently people drink
how much they drink in one occasion and
how frequently they binge drink
however
definitions can be complicated and it
doesn't help if people to recognize
their own drinking so we would recommend
everyone sticks to this chief medical
officer's guidelines or drinking no more
than 14 units over a week
ideally over three or more days and that
everyone plans in at least three drink
free days during the week
our advice would be to visit our website
drinkaware.co.uk
and complete our self-assessment tool to
get a really good understanding of your
drinking or what it might mean for your
health our website has lots of hints and
tips to help you cut down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
are women safe on our streets
that's what we're discussing on the
great debate but could part of the
problem be behind closed doors
in our opinion poll we asked about
people's views on access to pornography
we asked if you would support greater
restrictions on internet porn 63
agreed while just 19 would oppose it and
when we broke it down by gender 80
percent of women said that they'd
support greater restrictions compared to
46 percent of men
i want to come back to our studio panel
and ask you about this
sarah vine
how much do you think this matters
enormously i think it's a huge driver of
attitudes negative attitudes to women i
think porn hardcore porn which is free
to view online with no barriers to entry
to anyone who has a smart device that is
to say
an eight-year-old a three-year-old you
know anyone can see it
uh is
full
it is constructed
uh of violent acts on women and and the
way the porn websites work is that the
most shocking ad the most shocking
um
scenes the things that are the most
horrific are the ones that get the most
views and therefore go to the top so
they're the ones that you arrive at
first so it's self perpetuating so the
more violent the more shocking the more
depraved the more views they get the
more and and the and it grows and grows
and grows like a horrible cancer and for
years i've been
trying to get
this idea of putting porn behind a
paywall i mean you know i'm not a fan of
porn but if you're on a 21 year old then
you have the right to watch it but
that's fine but please can we get it out
of the way of
young children and the thing is is that
i think there was a report out recently
that said something
insane like sort of 30 of children age 8
have seen hardcore porn i mean it just
is that it's on their smartphones i mean
the second order the second you give
your child a smartphone most people give
their child smartphone when they go to
secondary school so that's age 11. the
second you give that child the
smartphone they can watch porn it is now
the primary sexual experience for most
of our children it's where young men are
getting all of their
information about women from and it is
damaging it's damaging hugely damaging
to boys but also to girls as well i mean
colin sorry is this uh something that
the police are seeing
the internet has a lot to answer for
it's the internet has a lot to answer
for uh
and and just try stopping it is the
difficulty try stopping it the only way
sarah says to stop it is not to have
a device that can access it but that's
not an option for you know parents in in
the counselors doing their homework on
their smartphones you can't take it away
from them
okay
let's go back to the wall
joanie cunningham uh i think you have a
question that you want to raise on this
eddie hello good evening um how's easy
access to online pornography led to the
objectification of women
what do you think joni i'll come to our
studio panel in a second what's your
view
100 i think i have two daughters um i
know i finish a generation that are led
by their phones and i just think and i
work in marketing as well it's
everywhere i think even from the
instagram social profiles
i think even if it's beared down i think
every step leads to something else and i
think we have a moral obligation
um to
to protect our children on the younger
generation that wasn't available when i
was growing up and i i fear for the
safety of our children i want to put the
journey's question to you has easy
access to online pornography led to the
objectification of women femi you're
shaking your head no no it hasn't the
objectification of women has created the
market for easy access to pornography
so the objectification of women has been
around
for eons what's happened now is it's
become mainstream and it's become more
accepted there was a time when men
looked at pornography and they kept
their materials somewhere in the house
where nobody else would find it now
people are just showing each other
things on their smartphones so the bus
people on the ball on the bus
and watch men watching porn on the train
so it's the easy access the
objectification has led to the easy
access it's created the market so amber
rudd is it just an amplification or is
it a cause uh i think it's i think it's
a bit of both but what i just want to
pick up too is something that sarah said
is that this pawn is not the same sort
of porn that feminist was referring to
that might be hidden in a box somewhere
in somebody's room 30 or 40 years ago
this is violent stuff and that's why
it's not just the objectification and
it's live as well it's live and it's
live but it's violent stuff so it wasn't
obvious 30 years ago wouldn't have
thought that the porn that people would
see on the internet would be so violent
it's objectifying women into violent a
place where men can play out their
violent fantasies that's what's so
dangerous and that's why you get the
connection between men watching this and
feeling that they can fulfill their
misogynist fantasies let's let's talk
more about whether there is actually a
direct line from one to the other from
porn to violence i want to bring in uh
noha mokhezel from southwest london now
i know i know that you have
organized a program
where women can support each other and
that you actually work
in the area where sarah everard
disappeared and a lot of your work is in
getting women to buddy up to help each
other to walk together and so on
do you recognize this picture that's
being painted about a relationship
between pornography
to
violence and stalking and all of
that yeah absolutely many of the girls
in my group have been uh stalked
uh by people that they know
um
with regards to pornography it's so
accessible
at the moment for all men of all ages
and it's really quite horrifying
um they're so exposed to it that they
start to familiarize themselves with
that and watch it over and over and over
and over again
until then they actually legitimize it
and hurt women um and sadly um a lot of
these things that these men are watching
are giving them um
very nasty ideas and they're reenacting
them
thank you noah let me um let me go to
our viewers panel as a whole let's go to
the wall
let me ask you this question
hands up who thinks that the government
should take action to restrict
access to internet porn
who thinks that the government should
take action to restrict
access to internet porn
i don't think i can see very many people
who don't agree with that thank you very
much
it seems to me that um
sarah there's
strong support for the sort of
proposition that you're making well
there is explain explain why this isn't
uh
a restrict an unacceptable restriction
on freedom of expression and freedom of
speech
well i mean we live in a country where
we have um we have censorship we have
like if you go into a film it's rated 18
or it's rated 16. i mean you know
we we have to protect our young people
from things that they're that their
emotions and their brains can't really
yet understand that's the whole thing
it's not about calling molly
coddling them all or banning free speech
it's about saying you're a child we
don't expose you to these things we as a
society we nurture you and we protect
you and we wait until you're ready for
this kind of stuff
sorry tell me you agree i completely
agree and also it's not censorship to
say you need to pay for something
it says it basically says you need to be
um
actively looking for this this product
and being willing to pay for it whereas
what happens at the moment is a lot of
our young people come across it almost
accidentally and there is a perception
you see um with with some young men
today that the the the sexes is freely
available to them because they see all
this porn and it's free and they don't
have to pay for it and they think that
they can get that in in a nightclub or
in a party in
a loop you know it's just awful amber
rudd for the government to take action
is a big step
should it yeah it definitely should but
governments are slow i'm afraid well
there's the online safety isn't there we
have the online well first of all we did
introduce
age verification seven years ago which
was a start but i mean it's been
completely taken over by events but
there is the online safety bill uh sarah
is right which is coming at the end of
this year which i hope will go somewhere
there's nothing in there i've read it
there's nothing in there
what could we actually do now to
restrict access wait uh sarah's got a
proposal right now okay i mean you can
restrict put it behind the paperwork
access to netflix you can perfect access
to anything these days i'm sorry we have
run out of time
we know that this conversation is going
to continue um i have to thank our
pandas here in the studio for your
contributions extraordinary uh erudite
sarah vine
femi
toju colin sutton and amber rudd
and i want to thank our panel
for your contributions particularly
those of you who have told us some of
your own personal stories which i know
was not easy so thank you all
very much for your contributions
and most of all i want to thank you our
audience for watching at home
plenty of food for thought tonight
keep the conversation going keep talking
we'll see you again for next week's
great debate